so good afternoon it's my real pleasure
to introduce not only a distinguished
yell alumna and a dear friend to yell
but also the beginning of a new lecture
series and it's electric series in which
I have a close personal interest but
I'll get to that in a minute before I
talk about our speaker though let me
tell you briefly about the inception and
the inspiration for the women of Yale
lectures I think many of you may know
particularly those of you in Yale
College that we are going to reach a
milestone in 2019 and that milestone is
the 50th anniversary of co-education in
Neil College and there is no doubt that
the diverse interconnected excellent
yell that we have today and that
enriches all of us would not exist if
that crucial moment in yells history 50
years ago hadn't happened and so my wife
Marta may be Marty you could wave your
hand around to people know who you are
Marta is a woman of Yale
she graduated from the School of Public
Health she and I were talking about how
to contribute to the discussion and the
celebration of this upcoming 50th
anniversary and she's been talking to
Yale women the Yale alumni group that
encompasses women from that era and
Beyond about what could look what could
we do what could we do to celebrate
women and create a little momentum
leading up to the 50th anniversary and
thus was born the women of Yale lecture
series and we decided to make it
presidential lecture series because I
love the idea and I'm not shy to put my
seal my stamp on wonderful ideas that
are presented to me as the as Yale women
and Martin and others did so we're
planning more visits by other Yale women
women of Yale in the next three years
we'll have at least one
these every semester I think is the plan
and we look forward to advertising them
to you and kicking off today's well
today's lecturer embodies the idea of
someone who needs no introduction now
some of you have heard me tell this
story and I apologize I've used that
line before it's a cliche someone who
needs no introduction and so you use it
with caution the last time I used it was
for Henry Kissinger who as you know who
has did embarrassing by as you know gave
his archives all his papers to Yale and
he comes a couple times a year teaches
our students lecturers and helps us with
the curation of his archive and I was
introducing him at a at his lecture and
I thought to myself truly this is a man
who needs no introduction and so I said
truly this is a man who needs no
introduction and I start to hear this
loud tapping on the stage and it's
Henry's cane and I look over and I say
dr. Kissinger is something wrong and he
says I do not do a good Henry Kissinger
but he says something like Peter I may
be a man who needs no introduction
but I am also a man who likes to listen
to one
so because because I had thought he was
a man who needed no introduction I
hadn't prepared one and so from memory
from a lifetime of memory I tried to
reconstruct a Henry Kissinger story in
front of a live audience in a way that
he would find satisfactory and whether
or not he found it satisfactory I still
don't know I've been too afraid to ask
him today's speaker is truly a woman who
needs no introduction but let me say a
few words about her nonetheless my Linh
I think has in many ways motivated at an
entire generation of Yale students who
have followed her story of rapid ascent
into the public eye which began at least
as the story goes so I'm told with a
senior class project that she submitted
senior year project that she submitted
to a national competition the design for
the Vietnam Veterans Memorial now the
most visited memorial in our nation's
capitol stood out from nearly 1500
competitors to win a contest and earn
her immediate acclaim I understand at
least continuing as the story goes that
the memorial rotunda and Woolsey Hall
with the names of Yale soldiers who
perished in all of the wars might have
been one of the inspirations for her
memorial but those of you who have seen
it how many of you have walked along it
and watching most most of you I know
that it's it's really hard to describe
that the emotion that you feel as you
walk down that path and that wall grows
and grows and grows right next to you
well my Linh graduated from Yale College
in 1981 she earned her master's from the
School of Architecture in 1986 returned
to yells commencement platform a year
later to receive an honorary degree of
Fine Arts
from Yale she's a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Letters American
Academy of Arts and Sciences the
National Women's Hall of Fame and she
was awarded the National Medal of the
Arts by President Obama as a sculptor of
an iconic campus landmark the women's
table in front of sterling Memorial
Library a landmark that I have many many
tours of many many guests I have tried
to do justice to in my descriptions of
she is a fitting inaugural presenter for
the women of Yale lecture series the
lectures the the table the women's table
is designed to commemorate the 20th
anniversary of undergraduate
co-education in 1989 and it honors the
hundred and fifty year history of women
in all of Yale's schools from the
earliest students actually in the Fine
Arts the school that became the art
school and through the Graduate School
to the present Milan will speak to us
today on the subject of typologies
process and projects this is based on
the monograph typologies that was
published last year before I invite her
to address us today I want to invite all
of you to stay after the lecture for a
reception that we will have just outside
the hall and you're all all welcome to
it I encourage you without creating a
funnel effect to notice as you walk down
the hall a piece on the wall on the
right side of this hallway which is a
study of the women's table I assume in
its design stage of maya lin's that is
hanging on the wall here it gives you
some sense of where the shape came from
with that let me thank all of you for
coming we're delighted that there's such
interest in women of Yale of women of
Yale lecture series by your very
presence here and we're even more
delighted that you've come to help us
greet and honor
welcome back to yell my Owen
thank you thank you Peter can you all
hear me I never know with my height
thank you for the introduction that was
wonderful
I'm also here I think I'm a its parent
weekend so one white daughter's is
actually running around I think taking
all the quizzes it was kind of shifting
clothing as we go from one season to the
next but she'll be here for the
reception and I'm just gonna get started
so I am as Peter mentioned finished the
memorial by 82 and did something
terrible I went to Harvard for a year in
graduate school in architecture and then
decided life had gotten a little bit
crazy and I wanted to reboot so I came
back to Yale and I finished my graduate
degree in architecture here but I'm
gonna take you back because what you're
gonna see is a sort of a body of work
and I've split my time between my art
and my architecture and I think now many
years later interdisciplinary and
multidisciplinary is definitely
something that we're talking more about
I think I was pretty much told in
graduate school that I would have to
make a choice
I could either be an artist or I could
be an architect but I wouldn't be able
to do both I understand that now wasn't
that they were being closed-minded I
think it's hard to juggle and as a
result I've made choices where I keep a
very small studio I'll take on one or a
contextual project at any given time
because I'm also doing my art work as
well as I'm deeply committed to the
environment I'm gonna end with the fifth
and last of what I would call the
memorial series as an artist I work in
series and it's called what is missing
so I'm just gonna jump into this if we
can down the lights this is one of my
favorite lecture halls because yes it's
a great place to take a nap and please
feel free to so I came to Yale to study
the sciences my advisor freshman year
was a wonderful man named Robert Apfel
who has since passed away
and I came to become a feel
zoologists I loved animals I love nature
I when I was in high school I was out in
the Kroger parking lot petitioning
against steel traps and boycotting Japan
to save the whales so I was a little bit
political I was very committed to the
environment I got to Yale and Robert
Apfel said well
Yale's animal behavior program is
neurologically based and it involves
something called vivisection and I
didn't quite know what what that was and
then he explained it to me and though I
kind of took a lot of science courses
and I love science I diverted my
attention at that point and decided
architecture would be this perfect
combination of art and science and math
but cycling back in I think my work is
all about the environment always has
been always will be it's an incredible
love and water plays a huge part this is
an image of a naturally occurring wave
called a Stokes wave I saw it and it
became the basis of a series of three
works called the wave fields and my
father was a ceramicist and I was
playing with my brother in his studio he
was ceramicist and Dean of fine art so I
was casting bronzes by the time I was in
high school
small-town Athens Ohio little board so I
kept making more and more things anyway
so I never gave up on the clay and this
is a material called plasticine it's an
oil-based clay and a lot of my works
that are these large outdoor works are
made first with model after model after
model in plasticine and the first of the
series came about with the University of
Michigan it's in Ann Arbor it's in front
of an aerospace engineering building
it's 10,000 square feet a hundred by a
hundred and the scale of this wave is
four to five feet so you can literally
sit in a wave curl up read a book it
started me thinking about what I could
do along that vein and it led to yet
another water-based land formation
actually it's what happens to the sand
by wave action as it's beginning to come
to the beach
head and it became a piece called
flutter very shallow wave formations at
a courthouse federal courthouse in Miami
and it's called flutter and each wave is
one two to three feet so again I start
playing with scale now the scale of this
artwork is three times as large as the
first one so it's 30,000 square feet and
the last in the series is at storm king
which is let's see if I can get the
pointer up outside of New York and I
don't
oops oh that wasn't good go back one so
I don't know if you guys can see the red
up here so literally this was an old
abandoned gravel field on the outskirts
of storm king they had temporarily
capped it and hid this sort of unsightly
gravel area with a berm of Earth so I
wanted to complete and triple yet again
so for me my series tends to be a
mathematical iteration and go to 90,000
square feet here with an the last of the
wave fields and to build it by taking
the berm of Earth that used to hide this
unsightly gravel pit and create the
artwork out of it
so I started and actually the storm king
was very nervous to let me work here
because it was a brownfield site the
state had agreed to a temporary cap and
we actually had to reopen the brownfield
site and recap it but it turns out the
state EPA loved it because to be able to
take a brownfield site and turn it into
a work of art was something they were
very excited
so again model after model and then boom
you're out there in the field working
with preferably a contractor who has a
great amount of work with grading but
also has a good sense of humor because
we built the piece and it was actually
seven rows and it was too small to fit
into and nestled into the site so I
ended up realizing after it's been fully
built and the waves were 12 feet high
that I needed to go
charger which meant I meant each wave
from wave to wave had to get bigger
which meant we had to rebuild the entire
piece and I'm about to tell him that I
think in this slide so the end result is
a piece that is seven rows they get to
be about eighteen to twenty feet high
you get lost in the wave but from the
upper bank you get a full view down to
it but from the lower area you get very
different experiences going through it
and it then Nestle's in and I think it
ended up being about five acres in total
so we kind of cheated on the
multiplication there but again I'm very
site-specific and I had to fit this
piece into the site itself and it's a
permanent work but I'm from southeastern
Ohio and there are these ancient burial
mounds from the Hopewell and Edina
tribes and they're still there you will
come across a very strange unusual Hill
in the middle of your farm field
they've been there for since the 1200 AD
so when people say well I don't get it
it's sort of living how how do you
expand on changing I said part of the
goal is that it does change now two of
the rows had underground streams in them
they're considerably wetter so as you go
through them at certain times of the
year they're butterflies they're simple
microclimate changes between each one of
these rows and of course cross-country
skiers tend to like it as I've been
making these large outdoor works I've
been having a dialogue with the indoor
works especially because as an artist I
need to come in and make some by hand
and I don't really drive too well and
I'm really bad at bulldozers or
operators so there has been a constant
dialogue between my inside studio
sculptures and my outdoor works as I was
doing the storm king piece outside I
created a show for storm king called
bodies of water this is a piece called
flow and again the dialogue goes in and
out constantly that piece led to the
largest of the earthworks not
necessarily a wave formation but a much
more abstracted idea of
wave it's called a fold in the field in
New Zealand each of the waves there five
of them go sixty feet high and the
models got bigger and bigger and then
out we were building the piece and I was
working more remotely and by emails and
we had a live cam because again I don't
try to travel that much and we built the
piece but the interesting thing I've got
to put my glasses on to do this the
transition between rise and flat was
really abrupt but we had missed the dry
season and it had started to rain again
so we had to actually wait a whole
another year to sculpt it back and
sculpt it down so again you got this
continuous flow pattern throughout which
again they were game to do so the piece
as it sits now and yes the sheep do
indeed help at times but there's some
very strange there's some yaks there and
llamas and alpacas kind of collects odd
animals there so that piece is called a
fold in the field it's about 11 acres
and another series again very large
outdoor earthworks is in Sweden a place
called vana six walk vac Meister estate
and I literally sat in their driveway
one morning and made this little drawing
and again I'm very interested in drawing
but I'm very interested in how a
sculptor can draw three dimensionally so
this was one of my favorite little
mornings and they came out and were like
what are you doing and I said well I
don't know yet and that piece turned
into what I would call is an almost
prehistoric line I feel like every line
has such character and personality why
does some lines look more abstract and
modern some look like a Bryce smart and
some look like a Rauschenberg some look
like a Jasper Johns and to me when the
Europeans first came to and found the
burial mounds in the southeastern part
of the States they made an assumption
they made an assumption that the Native
America
living there now were too primitive and
could never have built these so their
assumption was that Europeans had come
over built these mounds of which some
were in effigies they were and one was
in the shape of a serpent eating an egg
and then went back to Europe so I
figured I'd bring a little bit of
southeastern Ohio to southeastern Sweden
with what would become one of my more
historic pieces it looks a little
prehistoric from the start now most of
the artists live and work they were all
invited into the castle estate proper
and you've got everyone from Ann
Hamilton to Robert Wilson to martin
Puryear I needed a little bit more space
and they had a state-of-the-art dairy
going in and I remember driving by and
asking more marika do you have any Phil
do you have any excess dirt and she
started laughing because they had
literally just built the barn and they
had this mountain of gravel rocks earth
so we ended up you to seeing all that
stuff that they were gonna have to cart
off to create this earth work it's
called 11 minute line because
approximately that's how long it took me
to run it the first time or walk it the
first time and you can sort of get an
idea of the scale cuz that's a regular
farmers cottage and so this line is
about 1,600 feet long and you're allowed
on it when the cows aren't and they're
very very strict not only is it a
state-of-the-art organic dairy they're
extremely careful about its mouth
disease so they really won't let anyone
on until it's like winter and the
certain times of the months and then you
have to wear special equipment to walk
out on the piece but otherwise it's the
cows domain and I don't know if you've
ever seen a cow like I don't know a
feeding ground where there's a little
mound and the cows like to be on top
because they get to look down on the
other cows so yes they do like to be on
top second in this series okay could I
make a line that was a little bit more
almost like a 50s boomerang modern shape
it was for a private house out grounds
the house was sort of based on a case
study house so it became the Kentucky
LAN and it goes above and below and is
in Louisville Louisville Kentucky third
in the series and again I just began
playing with it would be a line what
would be a line that looks more like me
it's probably going to be a line that
can't make up its mind if it's a drawing
or language so this was just a little
sketch and I just started playing with a
different idea of a line not so much an
applied beaded event but a change in the
grade that's just pressed down so this
no longer becomes a form added to the
landscape but literally just the grade
change between a high and a low side and
the high and the low side flipped so
this piece actually is in a private
collection in the Hamptons
it's about 1,300 feet long this is it
under construction this summer we're
actually the spring and that's sort of
how the piece goes and you can then kind
of lean out here and sit in this lawn
there's no there's an eight-foot grade
change that kind of the site sloped into
a back wall and I actually use that
grade change to make the piece so the it
sort of now feels more level and yet at
the same time I was able to add this
line drawing in going back to the
interior works as I was doing those
outside works I was building works for
exhibits in museums in galleries of
which this was one of the first pieces
which is called untitled landscape and I
kind of think of it as an infinite
landscape though we captured motion is
that water is a sand dune I could
actually keep going with it if I had
wanted to and I think I'm going to play
with that idea and make one that
actually keeps on growing it was part of
a show called topologies and it led to
when I made it I realized well this is
kind of an isolated object
sixteen by eighteen feet what if I could
create a landscape inside that it was as
experiential and ambient in a way is one
of my larger outdoor works and a led to
an idea of what if I could bring a hill
inside and you could walk up the hill
and touch the ceiling so it went to a
piece called 2x4 landscape it's all
forestry initiative two-by-fours it goes
20 feet high you were allowed on it but
only after you signed a release it was a
little steep and from two approaches it
looks like a water wave cresting from
the back approach it looks like a
landmass again I'm intensely interested
in that space between things probably
because I would always say that I've got
this left side right side of the brain
mentality architecture or art I keep
them separate yet I think they inform
all my work and this was part of a large
show that traveled called systematic
landscapes it originated the Henry in
Seattle and there were three anchoring
pieces that gave you three very
different relationships to land one you
walked on and was this hybrid is it
water is it land one you walked through
which was a mountain scape near where we
spend our summers in southeastern
Colorado it's called Blue Lake Pass and
I took segmented almost stratified waves
of the earth and pulled it apart and
made the space between the blocks
slightly narrower than the block so you
kind of felt compressed as you walked
through this sort of stratified layer of
Earth or the other piece is the one you
walked under I needed a point Island and
as I start looking for mappings and
terrain and topography there's this one
singular point
Island Bouvet that was a ceiling island
in the southern part of the Atlantic
because most islands are chains like
Hawaii and it just wouldn't have looked
as good as getting something that had
almost a singular point Bouvet was
formed when three different ocean
fracture planes come together
up pops Bouvet and so water line which
is this piece what sea level was right
here so again if you think about it most
of our mountains are underwater and our
tallest mountain in the world isn't
Everest its Hawaii so in my art can I
again maybe it's that interest in
science get you to rethink what we're
looking at change perception of the land
around you anchor you this led to a
couple outdoor permanent works this is
for the California Academy of Sciences
this is a topo line of the San Francisco
Bay above and below sea level and I see
these as drawings in space but they're
more the way a computer sees terrain it
draws an XY grid and pulls it and so now
you can eat your lunch and you can
actually eat lunch under Angel Island
and the San Francisco Bay this one is
called above and below or now it's
called where the land meets the sea and
the funny thing and and again this is
how we think if we don't see it we don't
quite pay as close attention to it I
think we've spent much more time and
money exploring space than we have our
actual ocean terrain
you know our oceans our entire help
right now as far as overfishing as far
as pollution and yet oddly when I was
trying to get the datasets for this it
was easy to get the terrain above I can
get maps of the ocean floor but then it
took me as long to seem them together so
even though the land and the what's
above and below sea level are contiguous
we literally visually abruptly stop and
don't think of it that way so I'm always
trying to get us to rethink and it all
started with the series of smaller
drawings that again I get to make myself
are they sketches I think they're just
how does a sculptor draw and I draw
three dimensionally and these are like I
would say imaginary landscapes but the
question again is about ambiguity
what's the art is it the form
the drawing I'm making in wire or is it
the shadow drawing that is being
reflected beneath it and again it's that
connection between two-dimensional and
three-dimensional space
which I'm really beginning to play with
in my in a lot of my studio sculptures
this is another play on that when
systematic landscapes travelled I chose
a waterway of note wherever it went and
made an artwork from it I try to ground
you in something that you're in and this
one was in San Diego there really wasn't
a significant River of note but I've
been fascinated with just following a
crack or a crevice in a concrete floor
so I took out some dental picks spent
about a week with one of my assistants
and we just just a little bit more and
we silver leafed it and it is now called
the Depot River and it's there to this
day and I just to me it's like it's in
its again is it a drawing is it a
sculpture it's that ambiguous in-between
state and whether it's at the scale of
what I just showed you or I go to the
Strand and I don't know how many of you
know these strand the used bookstore in
Manhattan yes we love the Strand and I
go and I find old atlases and every old
book has a memory it has a past you just
sort of open it up to where it wants to
open up and then I sort of painstakingly
cut down into it two pages at a time
three pages at a time again not
pre-planning it but just take it a very
sharp exacto blade and drawing and yes
if you make a mistake that's the end of
that Atlas but what I do is I try to
follow terrain topography rivers maps
and until you really get into the US and
you get into the way we could measure
and draw and then delineate a lot of
states a lot of countries base their
shape on land formations because it just
made sense until you get to like
Colorado it's like let's just draw
square and then
go serve it so I tend to stick to
certain parts of minute outlets because
it's actually a much more beautiful
lyrical way of drawing and I just create
these little drawings again this is my
tallest mountain in the world this is
another set of drawings and this is
Hawaii I think it beats Everest by about
a hundred feet someone could probably
know that fact more these are just
sectional drawings through the earth
which have led to a series these are
three circles of topographic terrain the
Arctic Circle the 44th latitude
intersecting New York and then the
equator and what did this turn into a
little around the world times 3 and
right now I'm working on one that is
just a double it's an Arctic in an
Antarctic Circle so we're kind of
exploring that and again if you think
about it yes land changes but what's
really trans mutable is the water level
and if you took it all away
there's the land and we don't tend to
think of what we cannot visually see so
I'm always trying to play with that and
reveal that here's another type of
drawing it's in pins slightly different
from your sewing pin they're longer a
little more sturdy this is the mouth of
the oh I'm blanking the Volga River or
is the Aubry ver and it to me looked
like a brain stem and the thing about
these drawings is you're I can never
focus on it weren't when you're at it so
it kind of plays funny tricks on you so
again it's a three-dimensional drawing
with shadow lines playing a very strong
part and how you experience it this is I
don't know if anyone can guess it it's
at the US consulate in Beijing it's the
Yangtze but then the consulate general
said you know everyone says it looks
like a dragon
so again certain waterways and I love
focusing on rivers they're life forces
and we tend to think about where we live
or dwell on that River we do not think
of them as holes and I think until we do
we can't really begin to understand the
ecological damage we're doing and how
fragile they are
that's just sort of what it looks like
this one I love because it's temporal
yet it will be always fixed in my mind
it's the flood plain of Hurricane sandy
and it's a pin river drawing or pin
drawing and you can sort of see of
course New Jersey was hit very hard
Manhattan's up there and it came from
this New York Times image and I'm going
I have to make a drawing of it other
ones a little bit closer to home this is
the Hudson and the Long Island Sound it
turned into a recycled silver River and
again we always think of the positive we
don't think of the negative with the
figure-ground play on water to land so
check out the size of Staten Island
compared to Manhattan those subway maps
just don't quite tell you the truth or
this is one of my favorite estuaries the
Chesapeake Bay I've explored it in
numerous ways it started with a simple
recycled silver River waterway estuary
and I just finished this it's been
collected by the Renwick it was in a
group show called wonder and this is
literally my sketch ooh what could
happen if you could make water flow
upside down and so that's the way out in
this very formal gallery the Renwick was
our first national museum built as a
museum right kind of on the almost on
the grounds of the White House right and
so that turned into this which kind of
treated a historic architectural
building is almost ignoring it and I
just wanted those marbles they're like 2
inch diameter artisanal glassblowers
marbles they go floor wall ceiling and
it's almost like water will flow
wherever it can across the window as
well as on the radiator grades so again
just taking it over and trying to in a
drawing make it spacial make it
dimensional make it behave badly one
could say and this just I had installed
at Oberlin in their new visitor center
guest houses and it is the in aquifer
from southern Ohio to northern Ohio and
I'm from Athens it's you know Overland's
near Cleveland and it turned into a
marble waterway it's part of a series
again it's called the Ohio trilogy I'm
collaborating with my brother who's a
language poet Tomlin and with this one
ad we know van gaal a landscape
architect but for the first piece to go
in it's a landscape in three parts I
chose to focus on this river or aquifer
underground aquifer and it wraps the
wall and flows on the ceiling and then
the actual artwork isn't just that but
it's a garden outside this piece from
south to north and then we're going to
install a poem in a parking lot I always
wanted to take over a parking lot so
with that this is a poem about
migrations it is about coming to and
from Ohio it is about an underground
river that travels from south to north
it is about birds predicted to be
migrating into or out of the state due
to climate change and it's about a
landscape built for resilience so there
it is and we're going to be installing
it over the next year the gardens
outside and the parking lot is going in
in the fall I mean it next year and then
my piece the barbel pieces inside so
just to give you an idea my brother is a
language poet he uses words and almost
an abstract painter leeway there are two
spirals of poems one spirals out and is
inspired by species migrating out of
Ohio one spiral of words spirals in and
is inspired by species traveling in the
colored circles and dots represent the
wingspan of the 37 species according to
Audubon that are predicted to be moving
in or out the air again so again it's
sort of graphic representation but also
kind of a abstract
poetry with each of the species listed
and then it's range of how much they're
predicting that's going to change and
shift so yes I didn't become an animal
behaviorist but I think I'm extremely
obsessed with with the environment still
to this day and it's part of a series so
it will complete I've waited 20 years
and the site for me is the site of a
garden a site of an open space for my
brother it's a book and with this
Oberlin piece we will cut put together
at Oberlin a letterpress book that's a
book of poems about each project the
first one was called reading a garden
for the Cleveland Public Library and it
kind of gives you a hint you get to the
center of this garden and you can see
the title spelled backwards but it
reflects itself forward in the water so
you can all sudden begin to understand
that this poem was sort of about the
weight and directionality of of language
of words or input which was for my home
state at OU you it's kind of a
combination of my first relationship
officially with Ohio University was
trying to type out punch cards I'm that
old I taught myself COBOL and Fortran
but I couldn't type so I got stuck in
the computer labs just sitting there
making typos after typos so I hated the
punch cards so for me it's punch cards
for my brother was about childhood
memories and again how do you remember
something once you've experienced it
there is a core narrative but in a way
we you wander into this poem and so once
you've remembered something it goes into
the back of your mind and how you access
it is somewhat random so as you approach
this it's all about I wanted to draw a
map of memories or memories because all
memories cannot be located next to each
other so it's all his poetry but it's
basically a punch card played out in the
last one of oh you that had not been
touched and yeah kids go and play all
over it and you can kind of read the
poem and read his personal memories but
in a weird way anyone who's spent time
in
things because it's pretty random or
it's words can connect to what this
experience is I'm going to jump a little
bit briefly into yes I do architecture
though I'll tell you three things since
this is sort of kicking off women at
Yale I hope I don't go on too long when
they were looking at my competition
boards one of the jurors said he must be
What did he say he must be so great to
dare to do something so naive but notice
the word he the second time is after I
had gotten out of grad school I had
started making more artworks than
architecture and literally a male
professor came up to me patted me on the
head and said I always knew you weren't
gonna be an architect and I just I just
winced I didn't say anything so with
that in mind I do do architecture I'm
not going to show you too much this is
an in-between piece it started with a
drawing what is it it's a calligraphic
line and it ended up being a 90-foot
tall
bell tower in China that had to
withstand a category 5 typhoon and the
week it was a huff it went through a
category for a typhoon and it did just
fine but again to me it's just a brush
stroke and it's it's an in-between piece
the book topologies goes from art indoor
and outdoors to my architecture and I've
done these gardens and I couldn't figure
out where they went and I realize just
as my art has an inside and an outside
component so does my architecture and
yet when I approach a design for a
garden it's very very different then if
I were to make a wave field the minute
you would try to put a walkway through
wave field you'd almost destroy it as a
work of art but I've been drawn to
fairly derelict places in inner cities
at times just trying to repair by
putting in a garden or a park this is
sort of one of those gardens and again
we restored and created a front entrance
to this campus and this was what it
greets you as you come in and there was
an entrance wall that you can see
through led to a work that I just come
in Boston and it's for Novartis it's a
pharmaceutical research lab but it's
also it's almost a campus like building
and it's based on a microscopic view of
the human body of the bone and it turned
into an idea of in science we take
something from nature so this is a stone
scrim wall with all the meeting areas
behind it and then the tower that it
surrounds wraps around takes that sort
of patterning and systematizes it
because in a way that's what medicine
does it takes compounds from nature and
then tries juice scientifically make
compounds try to tries to figure out how
to make it this in the lab so I was sort
of playing off of that idea that's the
contrast between the organic from nature
and then the man-made and what I ended
up doing was master planning a campus
building for Novartis which was over
here allowing to them to bring all their
scientists that had it rented space all
throughout Cambridge this MIT is right
here and create a campus like building
with Toshiko mori doing the second
building single-speed doing a renault of
an existing building and then my
building there the trick was everything
along Mass Ave was four storeys we could
go to eight stories and needed to and
the single-speed building was two
stories and historic because the
importance is the ENIAC computer was
built there the other condition was
everything on Mass Ave had to be given
back to retail so how do I create a
front entrance and I ended up with a
wraparound building that has a high and
a low section so from the street it's
very low the entrance to the compound
and a public park that's about 1.5 acres
is inside here this is the entrance yet
everything along the street is given
over to retail and this is a chapel for
the Children's Defense Fund I did a
chapel in a library and I'm just going
to hop through it
I am deeply committed to my
sure but unfortunately we'll be here too
long so I'm just gonna show you pictures
that was a restored barn
I love old and new and I'm right now
working on Smith's library which will be
again a combination of old and new
I can't tell show you anything of that
though it will again combine that
gestural sculptural form with the
straight line
which is something I'm very much
exploring and all my work that it's that
tension between opposites it's a gentle
tension between the straight and the
curved the sculptural and the linear the
architecture and the art it's just all
part of what I'm doing and then there
will be five memorials of which this is
the fourth it takes place throughout the
state of Washington and Oregon it traces
the history of the Lewis and Clark
expedition as they reach this part of
the country but I was invited in by the
tribes who in the state of Washington
they invited the tribes to participated
they asked me to get involved because as
one of the Chiefs tribal elders said
excuse me
Lewis and Clark did not discover these
lands we were here and they thought I
would maybe take a look and I said I'm
deeply committed to environmental issues
I was about to start what would become
what is missing but in meeting these
tribal elders I realized how much we
were kind of of the same spirit and so I
started working and it's become oh I
started this in 2000 I've got two to
three more years started to be an
ecological restoration project as well
as a way to teach you about a place not
just from Lewis and Clark's perspective
but really from a deeper time history of
each place and using Lewis and Clark not
so much as a noun but as a lens as a
verb reading their journals and knowing
we have a time capsule moment of what a
place was like seen through Western eyes
exactly 200 years ago and this is the
mundane this is what we were met with
with every city-state
national forest service area parking
lots and restroom facilities and we got
them to do a transit study they were
about to double the parking and through
the transit study we proved they needed
less parking and that we could restore
returned and restore areas to native
grasslands as well as cite an entire
journey of Lewis and Clark you notice at
Cape D which is the last place they went
this is a seven part series you're
travelling through all these homelands
and then within each site every tribe
who's home one you're in blesses a site
and gives us a prayer and I try to
incorporate their interactions with us
in the piece so for this one they called
out the Chinook tribe read a poem and it
was always about asking nature to teach
us and show us the way
so I inscribed that palm on an oyster
shell path that traces the original
water line before they put a jetty in
and created a huge growth of land and so
that's the original waterway with their
poem inscribed but for me as much this
is the Columbia River estuary one of the
most critical estuaries in our country
and you were met with the parking lot
and an 8-foot tall hedge that went the
whole way so this is the parking lot
that they were going to increase in size
and this is a parking lot we were able
to convince them to take half of it away
and return it to a natural accreting
wetlands and for me working in any State
Park National Forest I stepped way back
I don't really want to be an artist here
I actually want the landscape to become
the experience though I couldn't resist
this was what was there at the other end
of the parking lot this sort of rusting
fish cutting table and instead I
replaced it with yet another columnar
basalt table and on it is inscribed the
creation myth of the Chinook whose
homeland you're in and it's about
cutting of fish the
wrong way and from the blood of the fish
Springs an eagle and the Eagle takes
flight and from this prom Oteri's you
read this text you can see the mountain
the eagle flew two and one the eagle
lays an egg and it hatches it's the
first people the truck so now when
you're cutting your king salmon you read
that myth and you realize you're in the
homeland of the Chinook tribe another
project and again this is a project that
blends art and architecture is a bird
blind for Sandy River the National
Forest Service decided to blow the dam
on the sandy so this bird blind will
bear witness to the sandy returning to
its natural course and on it we sighted
every species noted by Lewis and Clark
but then gave and gave uh gave a update
are they extinct are they in danger are
they a species of concern and over 47%
of the species noted by Lewis and Clark
are now endangered threatened or extinct
in the last and final piece which will
probably take two to three more years is
that Celilo Falls and it'll be a simple
arc that ends over the water and it will
tell the story of one of the most sacred
fishing spots of the Pacific Northwest
more water flowed over Celilo than at
Niagara Falls and it was deliberately
buried under the last dam The Dalles Dam
to go in on the Columbia and huge outcry
from the Native American community and
they have a very beautiful long term
view of it it's still under there it can
come back and with that I think a little
bit we did a little project at Yale and
I gather just say I I started with the
women's table you start with everything
I do you do a lot of research and for me
even though Yale went co-ed in 69 and I
was here slightly later than that I
think I got here in 77 and by the time I
got here I didn't even realize he had
just gone co-ed it was about four
five percent women at the time it just
and I think there's this really funny
fact that happens with history we just
don't realize and there was a huge
battle when the decision was made to let
women in and they only went in a certain
quota amount because they still had to
let one thousand Yale men graduate and
so it was a highly contested quota so I
thought it should be a counting game and
then the other thing was that as I
started reading of course there were
women at Yale from the time of Street
Hall I had heard the rumor that when mr.
street donated the money for Street Hall
he had two daughters who in his
condition was that the School of the
Arts would be co-ed from the start don't
know if that rumor is true but anyway it
became a counting game for me after I
heard from one book that faculty member
had referred to the women that were at
Yale even before they were allowed to
matriculate and they were auditing and
they were sitting in and he termed it
they were silent listeners and that just
sort of kind of gave me this idea well
what if we could just count all the
women that were enrolled Yale and not
from 69 but go back to the very
beginning this is like figuring out how
to make a shape on the rooftop of my old
loft on the Bowery that wasn't to
egg-like but was like an ellipse because
I kept thinking oh it should look like a
bit of a Modigliani face those are some
of the tracings that Professor Edward
Tufte did for me when I was starting out
with this and the Yale statistics
department got a little like they spent
a year counting all the different
graduate schools and there is a footnote
I don't know if you've all gone around
the back there's a little asterisk
because when they got to the Yale Law
School they didn't know because they
didn't the Yale School at one point
didn't wanna I think admit that they
were admitting women
so they were admitted as initials but
then they had to do an extrapolation
well how many of those initials might
have been men and how many of those
initials were women and so there's
literally a footnote from the Yale stats
Department as a disclaimer that that is
their best approximate guess of of that
year but anyway so we trace the number
of women at Yale when there were none to
the year I put the piece in and what I
love about when we use facts to tell
these histories and we use time there
are pulses so when there's a World War
there was a drop in male enrollment
there was increase in like the Yale
nursing school so you begin to see how
one you get to see the emergence of
women in society two you get to see this
counting game beginning to reflect our
our history and then this again is an
open timetable but this is the civil
rights memorial again I love using time
and this is sort of open-ended because
it can count from Brown versus Board of
Education 54 to Martin Luther King's
assassination for the civil rights era
but again it's ongoing the struggle and
we just leave it open-ended and then
again the quote from the Book of Amos
Martin Luther King we are not satisfied
until justice rolls down like waters and
this is in front of the Southern Poverty
Law Center or we all know that peace
again it's a time line it's an open book
begins and ends at the center with the
names listed chronologically broken by
the earth again you as a returning vet
will find your time and then become sort
of embedded within this time line so I'm
obsessed with time in my work I'm just
gonna end with the last piece and I know
it probably gone wrong so I'll do it
so what is missing which is what I say
is my fifth and last Memorial though I
donate to it I set up my own foundation
and I'll be working on it for the rest
of my life is a guerilla art work it's
like water it shows up wherever I can
sneak it in the first permanent
installation is at the California
Academy of Sciences on the other Terrace
from that wire landscape it's a like RCA
Victor you're your father's voice kids
sit inside it and we have films donated
by the BBC National Geographic Archive
and we have over 75 one to two-minute
films playing inside but they link to
our website which also has a lot more
content we've done something called the
empty room you go into a black box
theater pick up an optic piece of plexi
listen to the videos hold the species
and in your hands we took over the
creative time MTV billboard in Times
Square and for one month of an Earth Day
I tend to surface on Earth Day with new
iterations because again it is my
volunteer project the why before I say
50% of my mind is always on missing what
the hell is this
Philip wim asked me to do his 10th
anniversary collection I said only if it
can benefit what is missing and so yes
we did his anniversary collection but
what we really did was we repurposed 200
tons of toxin free organic soil and it
went to community gardens all around the
city and he had to tweet out and send
out information about well why is soil
part of this because one third of all
the soil of the earth has disappeared
due to erosion and bad agricultural
practices or that the possibility of
climate emissions absorption through
changing our agricultural practices is
massive but you might not know that in
America the lawn is the largest
irrigated crop grown and that every year
more gasoline is spilled refueling lawn
equipment than was spilled
at the
Exxon Valdez so I'm not trying to be in
the same place as the NGO
environmentalists I'm as an artist
trying to maybe get you to think about
it in a different way hopefully laugh a
little bit
this is we linked ourselves with Edwina
van gaal and her foundation perfect
earth project which is trying to get
toxins out of our wands if you can
notice what if you gave half of your
wand back to nature it's like I don't
know if you play the game go if you take
the perimeter there's a really great
chance you've won the game that's 50% of
your lawn so again it would be that easy
but this is what we're faced with right
now and so of course it's not the
species it's the habitats they need and
as an artist I'm trying to get you to
think of things that are missing that
you might not realize are missing from
just the scale of things so again what
we have to deal with is what Jared
Diamond refers to as landscape amnesia
and daniel pauly coined the phrase
shifting baselines every generation gets
used to what it knows so we don't
remember that the Atlantic cod were
bigger than men in 1895 and with every
successive generation we fish it down so
the scale of species the abundance of
species we don't even realize so the
question is how can we protect it if we
don't even realize it's diminishing
these are again bison skulls so if you
go to my wonky wonky wonky website sorry
it's called what is missing org it is
always improving it's a gorilla artwork
it changes every year it gets a little
more clear we have info section on the
upper right and then content of stories
it's called the map of memory that you
can access down below the stories link
past and present again time what has
been lost with what can be done and then
what I'm working on for the next two
years is something called green print
and then again what can an artist do to
contribute to the conversation that gets
us to think how can we rethink our way
out
this so if you play with the website you
can view these stories geo-located or in
time so you can click a button and all
those stories jump up a timeline there
are timelines of cities species and
waterways so let's say you take New York
it goes from massive abundance lobsters
were 5 feet 6 feet long Easter's were 12
inches in diameter and in time first
their sewage then there's industrial
pollution and then the ark Clean Air Act
Clean Water Act the harbor begins to
come back Easter's are growing for the
first time so there's an arc of Hope
like the Thames we did a history of the
Thames the Thames is the cleanest it's
been in over 400 years
so nature's resilient if we give it a
chance if we protect it so that's always
a message we invite anyone to give us a
memory something they've personally
witnessed diminished or disappear or
come back we're engaging with secondary
school so right now we're partnered with
WGBH Nova and we're taking this to high
schools around the country I can't say
who else we're collaborating with
that'll become evident this coming to
Earth Day but we'll have collectible
timelines species waterways and cities
and what I'm really working on is
something called green print and it'll
look at how we live where we live what
we spend our money on hopefully with a
sense of humor some of the things we're
doing is something called to save the
planet diet lose ten tons ten pounds at
ten years to your life save the planet
to have a sense of humor and what you
can do mapping the future so what if we
rethought how we spend our money what if
we subsidize good practices rather than
bad what if we adapted best practices
around the world
so here's maybe what an artist can do
what if we all lived at the population
density of Manhattan how much space
would seven billion people take up state
of Colorado
I did this so many times because the
math just didn't add up so it's not that
I'm saying everyone should live that
densely but 50% of us already live in
our cities by 2050 75% of us will the
power is if we can green those cities
and reform our agricultural practices we
could make a huge gain and so the
question is can we envision a map that
shows the future the balances our needs
with the needs of the planet can we
imagine rearranging the light knowing
that 70% of global emissions comes from
our cities and so we're beginning to
look at best practices around the world
as well as so this is what we can do we
can play with money so if the World
Economic Forum predicts 700 billion
annually is what it would take gee that
sounds like a lot of money and oh by the
way these are other things you're
spending this money on annually so
everyone goes to defense but just take a
look at adding up meetings in the US or
narcotic drugs or the weight loss
industry or them in the bottled water
industry so the question is we're
spending our future and we're spending
it every single year or this is what it
would take to save biodiversity
according to Lester Brown that's total
as a hundred thirteen billion annually
oh my golly that's what we spend on
chocolate worldwide so it's not about
let's not do with chocolate
okay buy it organic but it's about
scalability this is doable so the next
time someone says oh we can't afford to
go to solar because it's so much cheaper
to use fracked oil you've just got to
understand the scale of what we spend
every day on stuff I like the fact that
protecting all biological diversity at
the minimum level is equivalent to
business entertainment in Japan but I
don't know what that means or but we'll
go on to the next slide so so we're
looking at how we're consuming and
obviously this is all what I need
another two years on this but what we're
really interested is that intersection
between the major causes of climate
change and species loss
which is everything in the middle and
it's 49% of all missions comes from
land-use change forestry and agriculture
but you can go to our website and you
can look at things you can do what you
can do is so here's a little fun you
know obviously everyone says eat less
meat because the amount of space
required to feed the cow to grow the
grain to feed the cow is five times more
but we couldn't resist so we do things
like this who would have guessed that a
lamb is as bad as a cow and that let's
face it even though the bunny is really
cute if you're gonna eat meat the bunny
is probably one of the most efficient
and Ecko logically sound meat sources if
we draw to our logical conclusion we end
up in the bug world which you've got to
understand X percent of the world eats
bugs as protein but what you might not
realize is the FDA allows for at least
two pounds of bugs in our food because
there's no way you can get the food the
bugs out of the food when they're
pulling it up but what I then go to very
quickly because yes let's face it eating
a bug isn't so much fun for most of us
in the West why are they feeding
chickens fish and why are they feeding
pigs chickens so it's like at some point
one scientist said why our fifth
beginning to taste like chicken and our
chickens are beginning to taste like
fish so why do you think they call it
fly-fishing and what do you think of
free-range chicken is really eating in
the backyard anyway so perhaps we could
rethink the bug situation so couldn't
resist so we pull it to its obvious
conclusion if you're gonna go where you
eat farmed fish well don't eat a tiger
which is what you're eating if you're
eating a tuna actually you're not eating
a tiger you're eating the animal that
ate the animal that ate the tiger if you
eat a tuna that's how inefficient it is
and for me one of my favorite species in
the world is the bluefin Atlantic tuna
it is going extinct after Japan and
Spain America with its cheap sushi is
taking it out it is an incredible
species and we're about to lose it
so I gave it up I don't need to know
here's another one coffee second-most
exported economic product after
petroleum the difference it's 25 cents a
cup right we can all do it and the
difference between shade-grown
plantation versus traditional is 150
species of birds can live in a
shade-grown farm rather than 2250 so we
try to bring it back to home try to get
it back to what you can do
couldn't resist sugar largest crop in
the world probably caused a greater loss
of biodiversity than any other single
crop and you can buy honey or you can
buy organic but don't buy regular sugar
and then it tails you will map it so it
will take you to the regions and then
show you the animals at risk but what
I'm really focused on if you haven't
been able to tell is that agricultural
footprint and the amount of pesticides
we're using or the fact that the reports
are coming out that sustainable
agriculture could increase yields and
that regenerative agriculture could
absorb almost 40 percent of emissions
according to Rodale so this is eating 20
percent less meat from pasture and crops
and it is equivalent to all the
protected land in North America and half
in South America so again I came up with
the little phrase we can save two birds
with one tree if we can protect habitats
we can save species and we can reduce
emissions so I'm just going to leave you
with one final
Oh
Oh
Oh
so I'm just gonna leave you with one
little request if you have a personal
memory something you've personally
witnessed diminished or disappear from
the natural world or come back go to
what is missing org and share a memory
with us we're trying to build a global
online memorial so thank you very much
and I think we can turn the lights on
thank you everyone for being here just a
reminder that there's a reception
outside and you're all invited I want to
thank Pam and jock for making this space
available to us and Mindy mork's
for all the preparatory work to make
this lecture work today and of course to
Milan thank you so much thank you
you